did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them it hurt all vegetables all
vegetable I did so are we going to talk
about it what the elephant in the room
what elephant moms new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right help me bring supers back into the
sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me sweetie I'll watch the kids no
problem you're supposed to do a dad they
wants to do it I don't know that way why
would they change math math is math
hello hey honey
kit everything's great
[Music]
in track track he's in excellent health
that is freaky you know it's crazy right
to help my family I gotta leave it to
fix the law I gotta break it you've got
two more kids can have that choice thank
you young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
the screen slider interrupts this
program for an important announced it up
it might get weird I'll be there ASAP
[Music]
[Music]